[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy saturday it's mega wild card
weekend and you can plug those games
directly into our veins
welcome to the squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app
my name is cabbie richards she is our
betting expert and
the navigator of this porsche we call
the squad ride he
navigates through the wins and the
losses in the comments and the hoodies
that is greg ivory uh listen we gotta
salute the audience because you guys
have guided us to a
13 and four record so thank you and also
big shout out to devonte adams
caught another touchdown cash for the
squad 18 big ones this year
you are a legend speaking of legends and
great receivers
kelly last year chad johnson told us
that it's
very very hard to beat a team twice in a
row
all right so and also hey happy birthday
ocho cinco
we miss you tomorrow the titans
home underdogs plus three to baltimore
they beat the ravens
in week 11. they beat the ravens in last
year's divisional round
are you betting on tennessee to beat the
ravens for a
third straight time gabby unfortunately
i don't really think i want to get
involved in this game
to me this one is right on the money i
think this is going to be a knockout
drag out awesome game but to answer your
question
you have to look at the flip side too
kathy how do we quantify these two
things how do you quantify
revenge from the ravens how do you
quantify home field advantage this year
the direct answer is you can't we know
that tennessee will have some fans at
their stadium but that doesn't really
matter we've
seen that home field advantage even over
the last few years in the nfl
has started to dwindle anyway now
you have to ask yourself who's the
better team here on the neutral field
i think it's the baltimore ravens but
i'm not rushing to lay that three and a
half i think this is one of those like
sit back in your pjs hang out watch a
really good football game and
kind of plot what i'm gonna do for the
national championship game on monday
yeah you're oh nice shout out to the
ohio state i don't know why i brought
that in
but anyway listen on this show we bet
anytime touchdowns
we get gifted best bets from kelly
stewart and um
we meet some legends let's see the uh
these players have been rolling into the
regular season rolling into the playoffs
here are some of our favorite picks to
score a touchdown this weekend
on this look at this board you have the
nfl rushing leader you have the nfl
receiving leader and the overall
touchdown leader in alvin kamara
it is stacked very tough decisions to
make
uh and have a look at some of the best
pitches we got this week
[Music]
[Music]
the 2020 nfl receiving leader stefan did
lock it in baby don't ride with deuce
deuce this week when he's got a goal in
mind he's gonna go get it
you understand taylor baby
josh allen block of the week
[Music]
you know what i think that's a look
nice nice punctuation the cup runneth
over with talent indeed in buffalo
let's go let's go i know they're getting
pumped in the comments right now because
it is time
cabbie and kelly it is time shouts out
to everybody in the montage video
but you guys know what time it is
handy dandy ipad time here we go
in the comments cabbie and kelly
oh my god i got a good one here it's jay
it's jbsr says i've seen washington play
the steelers and seahawks
but really the whole season has shown me
that their defense can play with anyone
except the chiefs to be honest don't
sleep on them winning
hey it's jay i love that take you're
walking away with a hoodie i got another
one cabbie i'm going with the underdogs
indy cleveland and tennessee it's going
to be a weekend of
upsets i'm telling y'all dwayne punk
dwayne
pump you are walking away with a hoodie
cabbie
i'm loving the comments today they are
in here they are in here
hey you guys keep keep firing off those
takes i'm giving away more hoodies later
in the show
all right we have five new legendary
videos to show you one of them will be
our squad ride
of the playoffs so let's begin our first
pitch
comes from the delivering the picks the
prime legend
what up vr betting it's your boy here
delivering the pics to you coming to you
live and direct from my office
i got a special pick for you this
weekend anytime touchdown score
local kid fresno area josh allen gonna
get it done
lock it in let's go
got his packages delivered got a great
pick delivered thank you very much
our next pitch is from the clone legend
a knox 99.
one ping pong ball two clones whichever
clone survives is the lock of the week
here we go
jk dolphins hammer it up
also a big fan of the mandalorian josh
allen versus jk dobbins
g-money what do you got cabbie
kelly shouts out to my guy prime legend
man if it wasn't for him i wouldn't be
receiving my prime
uh amazon packages on time but let's
talk about the pick josh allen sitting
at plus 120
i mean josh allen got to show up today
in order for those
buffalo bills uh to win i mean and i i i
don't i don't dislike the plus 120
plus money man that look it's looking
real appealing now let's go over there
to the clone legend
uh i mean he got real creative here
kathy he got
real creative here shouts out to him
with the clones man
now i'm talking about the pick though jk
dobbins cabbie
uh i'm trying to find my stat here but
jk dobbins scored a touchdown in
six straight games on fire he's on fire
right now baltimore has the number one
russian attack in the nfl uh this is a
tough
one this is a tough one but uh kelly
what are you thinking josh allen sitting
at plus
120 jk dobbins scored in sixth straight
at
minus 112. greg this is tough
because we know where my allegiances lie
and they align
with my bets and i can't believe i'm
going to say this but i already took the
colts plus six and a half
yes i bet on phillip rivers in a playoff
game
i need him to make up for the last time
i did that which would have been
against the patriots a couple of years
ago that being said
josh any touchdowns here i need jk
dobbins to be
the guy so let's hope he is because this
one is tough for me again the colts
i'm gonna need a lot of luck on my side
today i have a feeling because why greg
who's been the hottest team in the nfl
over the past six weeks
you guessed it the bills
shout out to the bill's mafia jumping
through tables and all that kind of
nonsense uh
should i get in the comments here oh
yeah
are you guys allowing me to get in the
comments okay here we go
uh i'm in the comments and and and
they're they're all over the place i got
wade0821 saying
both allen and dobbin scored shout out
to you wade you're walking away with a
hoodie
tk tk244 says it's not a question
dobbins is playing the titans so i i i i
think that he means dobbins is going to
score
shout out to you tk uh just because you
just because you're here you're getting
a hoodie bro
pat guy my guy pat my guy
pat my guy pat boninelli he said take
the plus money
take alan he's rocking with alan hey
cabbie next one i see i'm just gonna
choose all right man okay
okay next one i'm gonna scroll through
oh my god
kp giants came in with the gif here show
you guys
handy dandy you see those gifs right
there you see who that is like jk
dobbins that's jk dobbins cabbie jk
dobbins
and the clone legend is moving on to the
next round
all right salute to you clone legend and
all your star wars toys
you're moving on to the second round
along with jk dobbins
let's get it our next pitch comes from
oscar 19
parkinson who's got it who's at a press
conference and he has a big announcement
to make
after numerous conversations family
friends
and coaches i have finally decided to
select
derrick henry as this weekend's anytime
touchdown score
go king him
there you go baby it looks like he's
going to the university of derrick
henry abby absolutely hey we gotta we
gotta tap
in and get one of those hats man because
my guy derek henry has been
absolutely balling this year he has over
2 000 yards as you guys know uh and the
last time he played this defense cabbie
the last time he played this defense he
put up 133
rushing yards and a touchdown and the
team also won
so that being said uh
i don't i did i i the the the
lane two point laying two dollars kelly
that's that's just
i i don't know but get talk to me you
you're the one that that knows these
numbers knows these uh
these odds better than me talk to me
about derrick henry
at minus 200 jk dobbins minus 112.
greg you nailed it look i don't ever
want to lay two dollars i don't even
want to lay 150
but our friends over at draftkings are
giving us an odds boost so we just got
to wipe
these numbers off here we're thinking
who is going to be the best
at three to one and bottom line that is
our dude
derek henry i understand i said
look i didn't really want to get
involved in this game to start the show
kathy i already talked about it
but is derek henry going to score a
touchdown yes he is
derek henry it's a no-brainer here for
me greg
kelly's rocking with derek henry let me
hop into my handy dandy ipad and see
what the
comments are saying uh okay my guy b
smith got derek harry over here gigging
y'all can see him right there you see
him gigging on it just went away but i'm
back into the comments
uh here we go silk oracle sick oracle
says
oh the comments are moving sick oracle
says 150 for derek carey and two
touchdowns book it
he's rocking with derek henry cavi this
might be a runaway in the comments
i got my guy wb wmbuhl he got derek
henry's sleep you see him sleep right
there
he's sleep he's literally asleep that
means he's sleeping in the pic
he's rocking with derek henry cabby it
is a parent
it is a parent landslide in the comments
derrick henry and my son and the signing
day legend
yeah excellent work okay i didn't even
where did he even find a gif of derrick
henry sleeping like i don't even know
where you find that but
you found it you put it in the comments
you're getting a hoodie well done oscar
19 parkinson
with your derrick henry pick you guys
have won round two
let's get to round three when it comes
to wise guys
nikki cass is pretty sharp so who you
got for us illegitimate
hey how's everybody doing it's play
squad so you want to know who's scoring
a touchdown this weekend huh
okay give me a second let me put on my
glasses
all right who the [ __ ] is playing this
weekend i got it
i'm telling you bleacher report my man
alvin kamara
on the uh what he was saying new orleans
chase
you're gonna score a [ __ ] touchdown
this weekend okay
oh here we go hey alvin how we doing kid
yeah i told him yeah i told him you're
gonna score this weekend don't worry
about i got it
all right okay yeah all right yeah all
right tell the fan might say hello
okay take it easy that was mr kamara
right there so now you got me
guaranteeing it
and mr camara guaranteeing it god bless
you
[Laughter]
legend bro i love that dude a shout out
to the
ill legenda yes i said that correct i
did take a talent in high school so
shout out to my guy
el logenda but let me talk about the
pick kelly
let me talk about let me just run
through some of the numbers that alvin
kamura
has uh has has just
created this season uh let's run through
it so christmas day cabbie you know he
scored 600
goodness yeah he's yeah he scored six
that shot he also had nfl
best nfl best 21 touchdowns
on the year he is bawling i'm
i mean i don't even know what else to
say my guy's been bawling he said that
minus 225 kelly just said that we
we and only us here can change this to
plus 300.
i'm i'm torn i'm honestly torn we got
two favorites here kelly
talk to me derek henry sitting at minus
200 alvin kamara sitting at -225
what are you thinking greg this is
really uh
man this is this is worse than the colts
pick i'm just going to be really honest
with you i have not got to the window
with this team yet
so i don't want to hear about it if they
get blown out by the saints
but the games that scare me the most are
the ones that are most intriguing to me
and the bears
at 10 has me going what am i missing
here this line should be
seven and a half but the bookmakers are
wanting to protect themselves
from everybody putting the saints into a
teaser so what do they do they take it
up to nine and a half
what happens they still get saints money
after saints money after saints money
so they move it to ten
and taking the bears is infuriating i've
done it a couple of times this year
and it's happened to work out about two
out of three that being said what i do
think will happen will
be the bears defense will stifle drew
brees at moments in time they have a
really great pass rush what's that mean
that means aaron alvin kamara is going
to have to run the ball
right into the end zone if the saints
want to win this game i like the album
camaro pick here
but i do think that line is just a
little too high again i don't know if i
can bet on the bears i'm going to be
really honestly but
hey come sunday anything's possible
anything is possible and guess what
anything is possible when greg's reading
the comments as well
you can walk away with a hoodie i'm back
into the comments cabbie and kelly
and it's it's another landslide i mean
for it's another landslide i'm seeing a
lot of
a lot of alvin kamara you see that
hopefully it doesn't go away but you see
that
oh yeah see that alvin kamara shouts out
to my guy
chris amiano you're walking away with
hoodie eric palke
you're also walking away with it he gave
us an alvin kamara gift i see i got
alvin kamara dancing right now as a gift
jay fry 14 14 you're walking away with
man this one hurts
king henry whoo hey harry cabby
he's just he just got he got a landslide
so it's a landslide in the comments
they're rocking with alvin kamara cabbie
yeah it's it's rare to see king henry
get trucked but evidently he did by the
commenter so
salute to the ill agenda and the alvin
kamara pick you are moving into
the final round whoever wins this round
is our squad ride
for a wild wild card weekend here we go
our final pitch
is from the alexa legend spencer freeman
has alexa got locks alexa go
all right we need a lock we're going to
get a lock alexa
who's scoring a touchdown this weekend
stefan diggs anytime touchdown score
there it is rad digs anytime touchdown
baby
kamara versus diggs okay this is tasty
man
hey cabby uh you know what i think it is
i i know what it is i know what it is
alexa's been tapping into winners only
wednesday
it's happening at the winners only
wednesday that's that that's what it
that's that lexus tapped into a lot of
things my friend
alexa i'm giving you a hoodie shouts out
to you
let's talk about the pick cabbie minus
200
stefan dicks he has been bawling this
year
uh he does have josh allen throwing him
the rock
uh he has four touchdowns in his la and
in his last four games cabbie
uh he he leads the nfl in receptions
receiving yards he's a boss he's been
bawling
sitting at minus 200 uh this one's just
tough
i actually want to go put this in right
now i'm not i'm not gonna lie
i i do think stefan diggs is gonna score
but
but while i'm putting this one in kelly
talk to the people let him know who
what are you thinking about stefan diggs
alvin kamara i'll be right back i'm i've
got to put this one in
why don't you wait till we get the odds
boost at least what are you doing
uh we already talked about this game we
already know that i'm on the colts and
that's absolutely terrifying against one
of the best
teams offensively in the league right
now and how are they one of the best
teams offensively in the league right
now
because this man stefan diggs again i
don't like to cheer against my bets but
that would just be ignorant to think
that stefan diggs isn't going to have
himself
a game here against these colts
defensive backs
-200 uh up to three to one i'm back and
forth here
because i do think kamara will have a
better day rushing against the bears
defense but
i think we gotta go with diggs
okay all right uh i didn't think you'd
go that way because uh kamara out of the
backfield too is
so impressive get in the comments tell
greg you know send them a gif
send them an emoji write a paragraph you
might get
you might get a a hoodie let them know
if you've got
staphon diggs or alvin kamara look the
last three times she been
on underdog she gave us underdogs as her
best bet
they cashed she has an affinity for
underdogs and an
appetite for wins kelly stewart please
give the audience
your best bet on a wild card weekend
you're right kathy the broncos got it
done for us and we're finally
making money to see some of the best
bets if it was all as easy as the 2019
season we would just be living on an
island somewhere
that being said i'm gonna keep this one
rocking and rolling i'm gonna take the
washington football team i did take them
plus eight and a half on wednesday i
gave this one out now
seven and a half with our friends over
at draftkings and this one
is interesting right my favorite
narrative we've talked about 100 times
take the better defense plus the points
now as we're doing the show my phone is
blowing up kelly is alex smith going to
play tonight we're hearing all these
different rumors
i don't think it matters because this is
a play against yep see our producers
just updated
alex smith must be out washington
football team up to
nine over at draftkings but that's okay
because this is a play against the tampa
bay buccaneers
kathy and i were joking before we
started the show i said this game is
past brady's bedtime he said what are
you talking about hell
let's talk about the primetime games
this year four prime time games
they've lost three out of four oh and
four against the spread listen when
you're a guy that goes to bed at 8pm
it's kind of hard to play an 815
football game all jokes aside i do like
the washington
football team and hopefully that small
sample size of brady being up past his
bedtime
helps get us the cash i am nervous with
no alex smith i will admit that but
again the better defense here i really
think that pass rush
can stifle brady and hopefully the
washington football team can keep it
close and we can catch ourselves another
ticket
look as as the goat brady can throw five
touchdowns in his sleep but
remember kids washington doesn't have to
win
they just have to cover and if you share
kelly's enthusiasm for the football club
and
chase young's enthusiasm on the
defensive line lock in
the football team plus nine on
draftkings get there right away
the excitement has been building all
shoji money we saw a couple of
landslides so i want to know on your
handy dandy
ipad so does the audience who are we
riding with
on a wild card weekend for the squad
ride
tabby kelly
handy dandy i'ma hop into these comments
let's go out it's it's back and forth
cabbie i'm seeing a lot of gifts today
shouts out to the gifts shout out to you
guys
uh riding with the gifts uh i got
ish it's hardwick he's going with alvin
khamer he sent me an album kamara gift
uh it's back and forth in the comments
back and forth
i see uh they're talking about you kelly
they're talking about your best bet your
washington football team
i'm looking for steph okay i got stefan
diggs here
call me ricky diggs about to be laughing
at him talking about he's gonna be
in the end zone
l i h-p-i-n-i-l-i-s 10. i did not know
how to pronounce that one producers will
get you because i'm giving you a hoodie
he's rocking with digs
all the way digs all the way cabbie
next one since it's back and forth next
one i'm just gonna decide it cause this
one's getting good this one's getting
good
next one i'm gonna just scroll and we're
gonna just go here we go
scroll land got one
step on dick's td over and receptions
mikey draco you're walking away with a
hoodie
cabbie it is apparent we are
riding with stefan diggs
all right who score let's go down
please please please show the graphics
so i can show the people at home
what us here us here
on the squad ride can do in us only
change the graphic please change the
graphic
you see it at boom 115 now it's at plus
300
us here squad ride we're the only ones
that can do that shout out to draftkings
make sure you guys come on over to the
br
instagram story uh we're riding with
stefan diggs to win
sending your videos get on the story but
remember
put it in the comments i'm giving away
run them comments up i'm giving away
hoodies let's go
make sure to tap into br betting social
accounts to get the link for the odds
boost that's very important
always send us your videos that's very
important tap in with g-money greg ivory
on br betting's instagram account
for the stories it's a very fun ride
thank you to all the commenters
thank you to our new legends we got
delivering the picks anox 99
oscar 19 parkinson nikki cass and
spencer freeman
alongside kelly stewart and greg aubry
whoa whoa
happy richard i was almost at the end of
the show
you're trying to get out of here i just
told you we have some pics to lock in
man
here we go the best the best part of the
show
is here chai town 45 winners only please
you're walking away with a hoodie
uh eduardo please say the please
you are walking away with a hoodie here
we go k
pots winners only pleaser walk away with
danny brasco
shouts out to the winner only squad
winners only please greg is goaded
you're walking away with a hoodie
where's only please lock's underwater
are you going buddy
g money g money we have we have back to
back triple headers baby we need to get
to this football man gabby real men
all right yeah all right all right all
right all right
okay all right in mac in mac you're
getting the hoodie in mac 32
thank you to the commenters we really
appreciate it good luck with your wagers
we will be back
next saturday for the divisional round
to give away more locks more hoodies
and to see some more meet some more
legends good luck this weekend
stay safe and peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you